I can't say where you live my bad yeah
yeah yeah I got the dog song I'm like yo
what are we doing here with that space
connection yeah so if you get some 12s
by accident just send them my way I got
you man I just had to ship you a little
you know carefully you tapped in with
p-rod yeah I was just kicking with him
last night that's that's my big homie
like we skate together every day we kick
it like I was just actually talking to
my my bro pat on the way here I was like
bro like last night it just dawned on me
I was like bro like
I grew up it was me it was me him uh
Tori and Tori Powell yeah and I was just
kicking with them you know they just
putting on Old skate videos just
watching filming like my OG's who really
took you know skating that level and it
was I was just one of them ones I was
just tripping like you know got in the
hot tub just chopping up just about
career stuff and I was like bro like
it's a blessing to be here I'm just like
kicking it with like my favorite skaters
right now you know like sometimes it
just be tripping me out and that's funny
you said that because I literally just
with them last night yeah I mean he's
the guy when I think of like Nike
skating I think again yeah me and him
are only shark together it's just me and
him right now the only two people on it
yeah that's big yeah